in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matt
and Melinda are with us hey guys how are
ya hey welcome welcome good to have you
guys where do you live we live in Reston
Virginia about 30 miles west of
Washington DC yeah very cool welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do a
debt-free scream yeah yeah how much have
you paid off we paid off a total of five
hundred and fifty thousand dollars Dave
oh oh and how long did this take we
start in January 2014 so 40 months Wow
and your range of income during this our
range was somewhere between 150 and 200
thousand dollars okay what do you guys
do for a living I'm actually a brand-new
real estate agent and I'm in corporate
law so I am a senior corporate paralegal
in Reston oh very cool
good for you guys so uh what kind of
debt was 500 it was everything other
than under the Sun David we had a we had
a house that we actually ended up
selling about two years ago mm-hmm we
had timeshares we had credit cards we
had two luxury vehicles we had personal
loans we had one canine 401k loan which
actually everything it was everything
y'all were like normal crazy so what did
the house so for how much we ended up
selling the house it was we owed 315 on
it we ended up right at 315 so it was it
was slick so okay another two hundred
and some change okay and did you sell
any of the luxury car yeah we sold one
that was a was a sweet 2013 BMW x3 and
green party yeah mom were the party
payment yeah oh yeah sweet car - well
the downside the the other side of that
is we've driven one car for the last
since since that time so for the last
two and a half years we've driven one
car so Toyota Camry
you guys went radical yeah what happened
40 months ago well it actually started
you know everything starts from your kid
and you know I did everything my parents
did and then the bond money - good
College and you know out tried out on my
my spending my entire you know early
part of my sales career but you know
five years ago I used to wait three
hundred pounds and alcoholic addictive
sports gambler I smoked two packs of
cigarettes a day and actually so weight
loss transformation started this whole
cycle five years ago
and so after after all of that after I
lost about 20 pounds and overcame the
the addiction so you've lost a total of
how much in weight a little over a
hundred pounds in that same period of
time really actually I'm in my first
year and from 2012 2013 100 pounds and
gret you lost a Backstreet Boy I did
actually I lost my wife and gained her
back all in the same good like the last
in a year so gore yeah so you know I
everything everything just kind of
unfolded and then when we found 2014 we
realized we had a mountain of debt and
you know when we went to financial peace
class that very first time I looked back
and I said this is exactly how I lost a
hundred pounds we're going to smash this
so financial piece was our gateway to to
you Melinda what happened to your man he
turned around why did he was a hot mess
we had went through a whole lot and I
went through a lot of Prayer and do we
had to come to Jesus meeting and it was
my last come to Jesus and I was it was
really come to it was you can love
someone so much but you know they've got
to love themselves too and it got to
that point we were in counseling and it
just came from one thing to another you
know and it started with you know weight
loss and just tackling everything at one
time so that was the catalyst
I was also 40 pounds heavier than I was
and I started a fitness journey Wow and
now I'm a pro can bikini competitor and
started running I started running and my
husband is actually now inspired me to
do that he never would have set foot
anywhere near a gym or even running
anywhere other than maybe to Burger King
well somebody was chasing him yeah yeah
yeah so you guys are here on marathon
weekend and as well I'm assuming you
guys ran the race yeah I did I ran
Malinda ran the 5k I finished the the
half marathon on Sunday so for you
thankful for your time two hours and 18
minutes nice Ron dude yeah thanks for
making it the hottest yeah Chris and I
were in training ROG where don't you
talk to me about I was thankful for the
excuse not to be in the RAF so it was I
knew the hills were coming but I
couldn't plan for the heat so it knocked
me off a few minutes but I was proud of
the 218 so you know but you guys are
talking a lot about health obviously
talk about finance you had the you're in
a spot where you were a hundred pounds
overweight in sports gambling addiction
and then now I've heard you referenced
to come to Jesus meetings like what is
this done for you obviously discipline
bleeds health into finances finances
back into health how has this affected
your spiritual journey well it all led
you know one by one by one and you know
I'm you know I was blessed with you know
finding some friends and mentors that
led me into personal growth and personal
development and into you know a great
platform you know Darren Hardy and the
compound effect and it simply you know
once I found and started uncovering an
done peeling the onion like simon Sinek
says and start with why you really get
to that you know what is that why and I
just did it with weight and then just it
bled into finance and the Nexen
obviously you know relationships and
then it got to you know Christ and then
to believing to wife were you know I
went forward and accepted you know
Christ about a year and a half ago and
was baptized year or so ago so you know
it's just that that evolutionary process
of just making those smallest decisions
that started five years ago that you
know put me here in Nashville or s in
Asheville you know three half marathons
and a hundred pounds and you know five
hundred thousand dollars in debt lighter
Wow and now it's just a nice income and
I mean what in the world what are you
going to do with all that money now man
we're going to it's so hard yeah that's
the first thing rather they get a BMW
yeah yeah we're gonna we're going to get
the the emergency fund a little little
fatter it's been it's been a little
worrying looking over there the right
corner my I've seen a thousand dollars
for a long time um but we're going to
get we're going to get another vehicle
so uber has been fantastic
we have you leveraged uber a lot in
Washington DC so you know definitely get
a car and you know one of the things
that I've I can share just you know out
there the people that are either less
than this for the first time is you know
you can make this as stressful as you
want or you can make this as fun as you
want we made this as fun as we want we
you know Melinda did fitness
competitions probably 10 11 of them and
they're not cheap we went on a few trips
and so we just cash flowed and paint
planned and you know made a path for all
of that so we could have you know enjoy
this journey versus you know screaming
and cutting at each other and and the
whole nine yards you know over the last
40 months so because it definitely would
have been stressful enough so wherever
you all are in your journey just you
know start somewhere and and make it fun
and it'll be it'll go a lot faster
you guys are inspiring I mean you had a
total makeover not a total money
makeover a total makeup yeah and and you
know we'll just blame Jesus for the
whole thing very cool I love it
all right Matt and Melinda we got a copy
of Chris Hogan's book for you retire
inspired that is the next chapter in
your story become millionaires and
outrageously generous along the way so
madam Melinda Washington DC five hundred
and fifty thousand dollars paid off
selling a house for three in the process
and a Beemer
two thousand forty months making 150 to
200 what a great story count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow Wow
very well done you two very well done
man powerful you know transformation is
just transformation it it is that was a
fun one for me because I've been able to
watch their story unfold on social media
did keep me a they were listening to
your show when you were tracking them
yeah and I did keep me updated every
couple months or a couple weeks really
and in lucky said you can make the
journey fun and they did who's always
like yes they office and I'm he told me
how much he had left and he was still in
a good mood so the thing is control what
you control don't don't try to control
what you can't control
there you go hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]